بالبكاء واللطم والصراخ تصدرت البلوجر
السوريه لما الاصيل الترند في عده مواقع
لما ظهرت
تهنئ زوجها باسل الخير بعد اكتشافها
لزواجه من
حزب دوره
طلعات والعزايم زي ما قال لكن موضوعنا هو
ليس مشاكل لا مو زوجها انما التعليقات
اللافته على الفيديو اللي ظهرت فيه وهي
منهاره تماما طبعا
بالمتاجره والسعي للحصول
الى اي مدى بالفعل هذا التساؤل الى اي مدى
يمكن ان يفقد المشاهير قدرتهم على السيطره
على المحتوى اللي يقدمونه على صفحاتهم
فيلجون الى هكذا اشياء
والله العظيم العصر
طبعا مشاهدينا سالنا الناس في الاردن ما
رايهم ولماذا بيفقد بعض المشاهير قدرته
على تقييم ما يشاركه على الانترنت خلينا
نشوف اجاباتهم
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا من جده استشاريه الاستشاريه
النفسيه الدكتوره غزال او هوز هوازن عفوا
بن زقره الامريكيه دكتوره ومعلش اعذريني
اذا لفظت اسمك بطريقه خاطئه
دكتوره الابتسامه قاعد تمسح كل شيء وانا
تقبل كل شيء خلاص
يلا يسعدك طيب دكتوره شفنا طبعا هذا
الفيديو وهذه ليست اول مره يمكن جميعنا
شاهدنا كثير من الفيديوهات اللي بتدخل
بصلب وصميم الحياه الشخصيه اللي بينشروها
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي من الناحيه
النفسيه شو هو الدافع اللي بخلي الاشخاص
يذهبوا الى هذا الحد في نقل حياتهم
الشخصيه هل فقط هو حب اللايكات وحب الترند
والسعي وراء الشهره
يعني والريفيوز
ملاحظ هذا الموضوع طبعا الاساس اللي هو
الانتباه النفط النظر او الانتباه انه على
فكره هذه طبعا ديها كثير
اشياء ممكن نقول جذور نفسيه انه الشخص ما
يكون عنده قيمه لذاته وما عنده احترام
لذاته
بيكمل من الخارج بكمل باكستنا اللي هي
توكيدات خارجيه انه الناس بتشوف وبتعمل له
لايك لما بشوف عدد مشاهدات عاليه لما
بيشوف حب الناس لي طبيعي هيكمل النقطه
الداخلي اللي فيه اللي هو ما المفروض يكون
هذا الطبيعي الطبيعي انه الانسان الطبيعي
يحتاج المدح طبيعي نحتاج التوكيدات من برا
لكن بالنسبه معينه لكن لما انت صغير
التوقيتات جدا عاليه وزي ما بتقولي مثلا
انه هوس او بزياده رغبه في هنا نقول انه
في عندنا مشكله نفسيه على فكره يعني ممكن
يكون لها شهور نفسيا دكتور هوازن يعني
اليوم احنا نقول بالامثال ماي هذري الا من
حر السخونه او يعني بطريقه اخرى
الصراخ على قدر الالم قد نتقبل هذا الامر
لكن الجيل الجديد هل بالفعل اصبح يشارك كل
شيء في هذا العالم من الافتراض اللي اصبح
هو عالم يعني تمسك الموبايل وتقول اللي
فيها وتنشره للناس وين الحد الفاصل ما صار
في حد فاصل
صحيح ليه لانه ما عندها فرق ويرمز ما في
وعي
بتوابع الموضوع كانت الناس تخاف مره
العاره تخاف ولا اشياء الشخصيه ما تطلع
للناس تماما
العين الناس ايش تقول عننا ما نبغى الناس
تشمت فينا او ممكن الشيء الثاني ممكن
الاجابه زي ما انت قلت ممكن عيب
طبعا عيب لكن الان صار عندنا جزئين يعني
في ناس من فكره انه من كثر الغضب لانه كل
حاجه كانت مدروسه كل حاجه كانت غلط الان
صار عندهم غضب انه انا هروح للاكستريم
العكس تماما احنا كنا كل شيء نخبيه دحين
احنا كل شيء
الاشياء الداخليه واشياء الشخصيه على فكره
في جزء من الدماغ يتم تنشيطه وترفع
الدوبامين اللي هي الشعور بالسعاده لما
احد يعرف عني حاجه
جدا
دراسه غريبه
بس هذا اللي بيحصل ليش لانه انت لما بتحطي
حاجه زي كده الناس يعني تعجب اكثر في
الموضوع وبالتالي يرتفع عندك الرضا اكثر
طيب الدكتوره وبيعجاله هل هناك مخاوف انه
من الناحيه النفسيه المتلقي لكل هذه
الدراما الشخصيه ممكن انه يصير في عنده رد
فعل ويصير اقل تعاطفا مع هاي المشاهد اللي
عاده نتعاطف معها من كثر ما بيتعرض لها
على السوشيال ميديا
ايوه طبيعي جدا وهذا هو اللي انت شايفته
الحمد لله انه الناس صار مره عندها وعي
احسن من اول مو كل احد بنتابعه ممكن احد
بنسمعه كثير من المشاهير لو لاحظت شويه
اختطفوا شويه بالفعل لان انت تحسي انهم
حقيقي حقيقي هم بيستخدمونا بيستخدمونا حتى
في الرفع الدخل المادي بيستخدموها
بالتعاطف الايه اللي هو يعني ناخذ التعاطف
منكم كانه باجبار عارفه لانه
يعني على فكره نكتشف اساسا ترى هذه من
الاشياء اللي هم بيعملوها من اسبابها انه
يكون عندهم نرجسيه على فكره لانه يبغى انه
الناس يشوفه ويكون مركز الاهتمام بشكل
يتعالجون ولا احنا المفترض نتعالج من هو
ههه بالعكس
شكرا دكتوره هوازن استشاريه النفسيه يعطيك
العافيه كنت معنا من جده
الوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات